[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM NIKL: Hi.
I'm Tom Nikl.
And today, I'm going
to talk a little bit
about cloud migration.
Maybe you've already decided
to take your business
into the cloud, and
you're evaluating
the right combination of
tools to make that happen.
Or maybe your heart isn't
set on migrating just yet,
and you're analyzing
the benefits.
Either way, I'm
happy you're here.
I don't get to do stuff
like this very often.
Now, there's no single
reason that businesses
migrate but a few that
come up quite a bit.
Tell me if any of
these sound familiar--
increased capacity requirements,
software or hardware refresh
cycles, data center
contract renewals coming up.
The list goes on, and you
should check out our blog post
to see if any of these
examples resonate personally.
I've got time.
OK.
Of course, every company's
story is a little different.
And so deciding if
you're ready to migrate
is really the same
as asking, how will I
use the cloud once I'm there?
Or better still,
which combination
of Google Cloud's storage,
compute, networking, security,
databases, and more can get
me to the most agile, secure,
functionally integrated
cloud architecture?
Phew.
That was a mouthful, right?
This can be a big but
simultaneously very
fun question to answer.
That's why, for starters, a
detailed cost-benefit analysis
is so important.
If you're not sure
where to start,
Google's trusted
partners can take
stock of your unique
operational landscape
with a realistic return on
investment for every choice
baked right in.
That way, you'll
know exactly how
you stand to reduce things
like operational overhead
and unused compute
if you work to make
the switch to the cloud,
all before you ever
commit to a migration plan.
Next, it's important to remember
that your journey to the cloud
is your journey to the cloud.
You'll decide if you want
to move stuff as is first
and keep it there, or maybe you
modernize it after you move it.
Or maybe you want to
modernize first, then migrate.
Maybe you just want to rebuild
a few things altogether.
So where do you begin?
For the workloads that you're
looking to lift and shift,
you'll turn to Migrate for
Compute Engine, a tool that
was purpose-built to move
physical servers or VMs
into Google Compute Engine.
It's fast and scalable and
has cool stuff like testing,
right sizing, and stateful
rollback built right in.
Want more info?
Here's a website you
may want to check out.
What about workloads you
want to modernize as well?
For that, you'd use
Migrate for Anthos,
which lets you upgrade
workloads directly
into containers in GKE.
That means you can take
physical servers or VMs that are
on-prem, in GCE,
or other clouds,
and containerize them
in one fluid motion--
a great way to migrate
and modernize in parallel.
What about data?
If you've got a
treasure trove of data
and you don't want to
migrate it over a network,
you can load it up into
our transfer appliance
and ship it to us
directly so we can quickly
upload all that data for you.
These are just three migration
options Google offers.
So when it's time to decide,
knowing which approach
can save you the
most time and money
is a question our professional
services team and partners can
help you answer.
Keep in mind that
migrating also doesn't
have to mean entirely abandoning
your on-prem servers either.
In fact, by definition, you'll
be in a hybrid cloud state
while any migration
project progresses.
But with Anthos, we
make managing hybrid
and multicloud easier
than ever before,
giving you the flexibility
to craft your ideal hybrid
or multicloud, even
while performing
on migration in parallel.
Learn about the most
common patterns of cloud
hybridization and
multicloud here.
Now if after the
analysis, you determine
that going fully serverless
is the best path forward,
you've got plenty of ways
for you to rebuild things
in the cloud as needed as well.
You can read about the
two main approaches
and what makes them
different here.
OK, that was a lot to process.
The honest answer?
Every digital
transformation is unique
and you'll probably end up
mixing and matching strategies.
So what we want you
to know is this.
We have the technology
you need, and we're here
to help you craft the cloud
and the migration journey that
makes the most sense for you.
OK.
Now that you've
patiently listened to me
talk at you for
three minutes, I'm
going to hand the controls back.
The migration process
can seem daunting,
but the Google Cloud
Adoption Framework
is a great place to start, as
is our migration center website.
And with that, I say bon voyage
on your migration journey.
And thank you so much for
taking the time to listen today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]